hey what's up everyone Gerald here from
Geek culture and I've been using the
Samsung Galaxy Z flip for a few months
now it's my daily driver and well the
rest of the office loves the Apple
phones I'm pretty much the only Samsung
guy and Android guy right now
I'm halfway today hey come on Xeno
behind the camera
he's moving over to Apple right now one
question they have always been asked is
how will it stand up the test of time
will it even go the distance I've been
using this for about two months now and
it's pretty good actually and so these
are all the questions that have been
asked on our previous videos
so let's get into it
[Music]
hey guys before I go into my own
personal hell or flipping this phone for
a thousand times I really need your help
to help subscribe
hit the button below most of your folks
who are watching this videos or our
videos in the past few months have not
really subscribed to the channel so your
subscription really goes a long way we
have a lot more cool stuff coming up so
please do so hit that subscribe button
right now okay everyone it's now 1 14.
we're gonna start this test this phone
has been off the charger at around 7 30
a.m this morning and you can see it's at
50 battery already I'll say right now
for this phone the weakest part of the
z-flip 3 is that its battery life isn't
the greatest
but we have to work with what we have
unfortunately you have to see how it
goes the distance after 1000 flips or if
this camera runs out the juice so let's
get started
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven
twelve
thirteen fourteen
fifteen
sixteen
seventeen
eighteen
nineteen
twenty Twenty One
day two three
four
five
26 27
38 39
oh 30.
32 33 34
36 37 38 39
40 41 42 43
44. get back to Abby 45 46 47 48
49 50 or 50 you need 51 32 33 54.
V7
58 59
60 61 62 63 so 64 65 66
70. 21 say two 73 74 75 76 77
79 80.
E1 A2 A3 E4
E5 it is six
87 88 89
90 31 92 93 94 95 96 97 98
100 10 percent
101 102 103 wanna four and a five and
six 107 108 109
10 11
112 113 104 one five another one six
four one seven one one eight one one
nine one twenty twenty one twenty two
one twenty three
foreign six
27 28 and 29 130 and 31 32 or 33 34 135
136 137 38 39
140 41
42 143 144 I'm 45 I'm 46 147 148 149 150
151 or 52 153 154 155 156 157 58 and 59
160 161 162 163 164.
five play it right
169 nice
[Music]
75 176 177 178 179 180 181 182 183 184
185 186 187 188 189 190 181 192 193 194
186 187 198 199
200. okay everything looks to be okay
yeah
one two three one two
two one
two two two three Hoops two four two
five two six two seven two eight two
nine two ten
to eleven to twelve to thirteen to
fourteen to Fifteen to sixteen to
Seventeen to eighteen to nineteen to
twenty two Twenty One
222 223 224 235 226 227 228
to 30. oh my hands are higher
one
two three two three three two three four
two three five two three six two three
seven two three eight two three nine
240 two four one two four two two four
three two four four two four five
two four six two four seven two four
eight two four nine two fifty two five
five
four
six
seven
eight
59 260 261 262.
three the 65
265 266.
267 this is
nice
there's only two 73 274 275 276 277 278
279 28 20 21
32 23
4 25
286 287 288 289 290
95 96 297 298 29 99
oh nice three one two two three two four
two five
six two seven two eight two nine
q9
310.
311 312 313 314 315 316
317 318 319 320 3 21.
322-3323-324-325-326-327-328-329
three two nine three three zero two
three one
332 333
4 235 to G6
G7 238 339 340 341 342 343
344 345
346 347 348 249 350 three five one three
five two three five three three five
four three five five three five six
three five seven three five eight three
five nine
360. 361 you know
263 264 which is 65
6 which G7 260 68 369
274 275 276 277 278 279 380 381 382 283
284 285 286
37 388 389 390 391 392 393 394 395 296
397 398 299 400. nice for one four two
four three four four four five my hand
scraping
four six four seven
four eight four nine
four ten for eleven
for twelve or thirteen or fourteen
for fifteen for sixteen or seventeen
for eighteen four nineteen four twenty
four to one
four two two four two three four two
four four two five four to six four two
seven four two eight four to nine four
fifty four five one
four five two four five three
four five
four four five five four five six four
five seven four five eight four five
nine
four sixty or 61 462 463 464 465 466 467
468 469 nice
771 yeah
73 174 475 476 477 478 179 480.
481 42 483 484 485 486 47 48 49
490 21
292 183 494 495 496 497 498 489
500 halfway there let's go five one fire
two four three four five five six five
oh seven five eight five oh nine five
eleven five twelve Five Thirteen five
fourteen
5 15 5 16 help me guys by Seventeen five
five eighteen
five nineteen five twenty the phone is
getting warm five two one five two two
five two three five two four five two
five five two six five two seven five
two eight five two nine five three zero
five three one five three two five three
three five three four five three five
five three six five three seven five
three eight five three nine five forty
home hands
five five four one five four two
five four three five four four five five
five five five five five six five five
seven five five eight five five nine
Five Sixty Five Sixty one 52 563 64.
65 56 I think I do no no no okay fifty
Seven that's the eight five because my
pendants man
this one actually two 73 that's only
four that's 85 Plus 96 by 77 and 78 by
550. 51 52 583 584 probably
586 587 i88
590.91 592 593 594 595 596 187 of 98 599
[Music]
600.602 603
604-605-606-607-608 609
six
ten yeah six eleven six twelve six
thirteen six fourteen six fifteen six
sixteen six Seventeen six eighteen six
nineteen six twenty
ah six two one six two two six two three
six two four six two five six two six
six two seven six two eight six two nine
six two 63
C5
640 641 642 43 644 645 46 647 648
649 650 61 62 63 6 four six fifty five
six fifty six six five seven six five
eight six five nine six seven six sixty
six sixty six four one six six two six
six three six six four six six five six
six six six six seven six six eight six
six nine nice nice six
70 671
72 73 74 675 676 677 678 679 680 okay
I'll do this one two six eight three six
eight four six eight five six eight six
six eight seven six eight eight eight
eight fifteen nine six eight six nine
zero six nine one six nine two six nine
three six nine four six nine five six
nine six six nine seven six nine eight
six nine nine seven hundred yeah what
was that 701 702 703 704 705
707-708-709 710 let's do this seven
eleven
seven two seven one three seven one four
seven one five seven one six seven one
seven seven one eight seven one nine
seven twenty seven two one seven two two
seven two three seven two four seven two
five seven two six seven two eight seven
two nine seven three zero seven three
one seven three two seven three three
seven three four seven three five seven
three six seven three
seven seven three eight seven three nine
seven four zero seven four one seven
four two seven four three seven four
four seven four five seven four six
seven four seven seven four eight seven
four nine seven five zero seven five one
seven five two seven five three seven
five four seven five five seven seven
five six seven five seven seven five
eight seven five nine seven sixty
Seventeen sixty one seven six two seven
six three seven six four seven six five
seven six six seven six seven seven six
eight seven six nine nice
774 775 776 77
778 779 780 781 782 783 784 785 786 787
779 790 791 792 793 794 795 796 797 798
799 800 2004 okay
804 805 806 807 809 8 10 8 11 12 13 14
15 17 8 19 8 20.
eight two one eight two two eight two
three eight two four eight two five
eight to six eight two seven eight two
nine eight eight two eight eight two
nine eight three zero eight three one
eight three two eight three three eight
three four eight three five eight three
seven eight three six seven eight oh
eighty six eight three six eight three
seven eight
eighty nine
eight four zero eight four one eight
four two eight four three eight four
four eight four five eight four six
eight four seven eight four eight eight
four nine eight five zero
five eight six zero eight six one eight
six two eight six three eight six four
eight six five eight six six eight six
seven eight six eight eight nine nine
nice eight seventy eight seventy one
eight seventy two eight seventy three
eight seventy four eight seventy five
eight seventy six eight seventy seven
it's only eight eight seventy nine eight
eighty eighty one eight eighty two eight
eighty three eight eighty four eight
eighty five eight eighty six eight
eighty seven eight
eighty nine eight nine zero eight ninety
one eight nine two eight ninety three
eight nine four eight nine five eight
nine six eight nine seven eight nine
eight nine three nine nine nine hundred
nine hundred okay final stretch yeah
nine
904 905 906
907 908 909 910 they say it gonna be
done 9 11 9 12 9 13 9 14 9 15 9 16 9 17
9 18 9 19 9 20 9 21 92 93 924 925 926
9939 930 931 932 933 934 935 936
937 938 9 39 9 40 9 41 942 943 944 945
946 947 948 941
and 942 943 944 945 946 947 948 949 950
951 952 953 954 955 956 957 958 959
960. 961
oh there's two sd3 and 64 this is D5 and
66 and 67 1968 969 nice
970 971 972 and 23 and 24 and 35 and 26
1977 1978 1979 980 91 92 983 1954 95
986 97 98 89 990 yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
for you guys man for Content so
1001 2001 1002.
1008 1009
1011 1012 1013 2014 2015 2016
1018 1019 and
1020. okay let's take a look at the
phone
outside of there
if we can look in the middle bar
it's a bit Dusty if you have
fingerprints it is still pretty much
pristine how we actually got it in the
first place anyway and let's look at
battery life this phone is actually
getting a bit hot oh we started off with
what 41 49 of battery we're down to 25
battery so just opening and closing this
gets you down to 25 battery life so
Xenia asked how does a civil feel like
there is a few if you look at it right
open and closing you can see the Samsung
logo here
and if you close it
you can see that they are like the two
sheets or the displays actually going
underneath there's a bit of friction as
you open and close
my otherwise it's actually pretty good
does it feel any different no it feels
the same it's not any looser it still
has
the same type of I'll say the the
tension strength from the first day I
got it so yeah Samsung pretty good
you've done this for camera and
because it really stays through all this
well we have to go to our sponsor right
now this video is brought to you by
secret lab here at geek culture we love
our circular chairs especially the
all-new 2022 Titan Evo with its revamped
four-way lumbar system for enhanced back
support if PU leather 2.0 isn't your cup
of tea then consider the all-new soft
weave even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely Frost blue the
Tyson Evo is even magnetized along the
head pillow to stick on the headrest of
course there are even more new features
so do check them out at secretlab.co
okay folks we've been flipping this
phone for 1000 times and well if you
look at it right it's pretty hot the
phone itself is down to 25 from where we
actually started so opening and closing
your phone too many times
actually puts a strain on the battery of
this phone itself
it still feels great no doubt I don't
see there's any creases or anything when
it comes to the screen itself and it
looks as fantastic as the first day I
got it I guess this is where battery
life really affects the spawn here and
that's how it really contributes to this
not so ideal battery life will we see a
better Improvement in the Z flip 4
possibly we never know let's see how
Samsung improves on this phone next year
now that we have done with this video
itself please help us out by following
us on all our social channels and with
that if any comments or any thoughts
about this video itself you want us to
go all the way to 2000 let us know in
the comments section below with that
being said this is Gerald signing off
[Music]
foreign